and we need to know how i'm not gonna
talk about it anymore
oh sh oh that's part of the wall now
that is a feature of the wall
wow that's a strong man they put my ass
in jail for 30 years for
30 years people running tests he was a
hero
taking my blood even your people weren't
done with me
hydra i see him get out of my house
you better get out of his house that man
is rightfully angry
they did this man dirty welcome back to
new rock stars the falcon of the winter
soldier episode 2 confirmed our theories
that the black captain america or just
captain america all right
isaiah bradley is here to make us
rightfully pissed off
while planting the seeds for the mcu's
young
avengers this is inside marvel it's new
rock stars after show for the falcon the
winter soldier i'm eric voss
i'm here with mt how you doing empty
what'd you think of this episode oh this
episode was
fantastic it was like better than
episode one
and it was just action-packed and just
amazing and i'm just looking forward to
talking about it yeah i'm surprised
we're already revealing some some stuff
here with uh with isaiah
bradley with getting more into the power
broker and the flag smashers and what
their whole relationship is
this is our after show everybody we're
going to react to the big moments and
answering your biggest
wtf switch to us stands for what
the although people did start calling
bucky buck this episode so we could do
what the
book but i don't want to be steven calls
him buck only steve
yeah it's a steve thing which i like
it's kind of like a callback where it's
like
his friends call him cap but only
friends could call him captain right
so in this episode we saw that john
walker has quite the resume
and it looks like a bit of imposter
syndrome though it
seems we don't know what's really going
on in his cyborg brain and we also meet
his buddy lamar hoskins who is confirmed
to be
battle star yeah uh that is clay
bennett's character and uh they kind of
crash a mission that bucky and sam are
on
and it ends up in this failed attempt to
capture the flag smashers on this
high-speed
heist of vaccine stolen from a
mysterious power broker
who it has like a texting relationship
with carly morgenthau but she doesn't
tell the rest of her team about it
she's like what's on your phone nothing
nothing nothing oh you text someone
why how does he have your number but you
don't have his right
are you texting anyone that's gonna kill
us by any chance no
no no it's fine so
in this attempted team-up between the
teams bucky and sam tell john walker to
essentially falcon off
and uh then at the end of the episode
after meeting isaiah bradley
uh and his son eli bradley uh they
decide to
go talk to zemo about past hydra
operations now
hydra could have been involved with this
um that should work out perfectly fine
at all yeah i'm sure if uh
you have um you know a presidential
pardon and
cops in baltimore will arrest you i'm
sure they'll let you travel
internationally now
uh so sure let's go to europe and see if
we can uh
break a super criminal out of prison why
not
it's just a fun thing to do i mean it
will be very fun for us
um so in this episode mt and i are going
to talk about why isaiah bradley is so
so important and why his grandson eli
bradley might be even more important to
mcu
we're gonna talk about who the power
broker is and why
john walker just seems so darn perfect
oh real quick i want to show you guys
something
[Music]
uh so this is our latest obsession shirt
i meant to put it on at the start of the
episode i'm not going to change shirts
on camera because
uh yeah why why
if you can suck that udder for free i
don't know this
i don't know how it works um
anyway you can get this shirt at uh
newrockstarsmerch.com
it's it's a really cool design it's
inspired by the end credits of these
falcon winter soldier episodes but the
cool thing about this is
when you do get it you'll unlock an
additional option to write in a custom
shout out that will appear
at the bottom of these inside marvel
after shows like for example we had a
bunch of great comments lauren mizuba
said hi eric and mt
it's only been one episode but i love
your reactions
thank you lauren so nice you got me that
nice
cheese you're nice if all comments could
be as nice as yours
no no um wes sager says will sam's
sister end up joining the flag smashers
are scrolls present in the series i.e
rhodes um
i don't know if sam's sister will join
the flag smashers but i do think skrulls
are everywhere
because they've been in the past two
marvel titles so why not this one
and i think roadie's a good candidate
for someone who might be a squirrel oh
yeah for sure
4 100 good candidate i'm not saying
rhodey is a scroll i'm just
i am i'm just kidding nobody's thinking
okay don't worry
it doesn't matter if i say it or not uh
people are going to just say i said the
most
stupid [ __ ] and then attribute it to
me on twitter and i'll have to say i
didn't
actually say hey word was mephisto but
because some other person who has
thumbnails like me
did now i have to own up to it whatever
the internet am i right
uh oh and our friend carol brown said
hey eric and mt did y'all
just love how bucky's therapist
threatened him with a notebook
uh i love that that's like the pen is
truly mightier than the sword
when it comes to bucky's therapy i love
that i mean like you know bucky
uh has a weakness with notebooks
apparently because uh a notebook kind of
activated him in the first place with
zemo
so he's like oh maybe not notebooks
maybe no my greatest weakness my only
weakness
words on paper journals not
college rules
i love it um all right empty let's uh
dive into our first what the falcon what
is it
first off the falcon of the day is who
the falcon
is isaiah bradley now that's a fantastic
question and
isaiah bradley was introduced in 2003 as
the black captain america
figure as everyone seems to already have
a general idea and this
episode definitely gets into um and he
was given the super soldier serum via
project rebirth
which was an attempt to recreate captain
america super soldier serum which is
you know pretty hard to do because cap
is uh one and done and
the guy that made it got shot in the
first avenger if you guys don't remember
um and his existence was kept as a
secret though many notable black figures
came to visit him
as well as many black superheroes like
goliath luke cage
falcon there's just a lot of respect in
the in the black superhero community
for isaiah bradley and rightfully so he
yeah he served he yeah he is a a
trailblazer a true pioneer
and uh in the mcu it's a bit different
falcon didn't know of his existence and
he feels really resentful that that
whole history was hidden from him
because that would have helped him feel
more comfortable as an avenger knowing
that there was some other black super
soldier
that he could have looked to as a mentor
and uh i mean bucky's reason for not
telling him
telling him is well one he was a winner
soldier for decades and decades he
didn't start becoming sam's brand until
recently
yeah but two like he's like this old
guy's been through so much
i didn't you know he clearly prefers his
isolation
uh and he doesn't want to be in the
spotlight anymore because
last time he was in the spotlight they
ended up dragging him into jail
uh and that sucked um carl lumley's
performance
as isaiah was chilling amazing he wasn't
even in that for that long but i was
like yep this man an emmy good god
yeah like i felt so bad yeah he's like
he definitely played like 20 years older
than he actually is
like the age that he played the
bitterness just like
uh simmering under the surface surface
until it explodes
like when he chucks what was that it
looked like a like a like a
like a cigarette thing or like a cigar
yeah a cigarette tin yeah i
i don't know like some pills in there or
something i don't know yeah that could
be helping him or
yeah those things they're just they're
pretty flimsy if you would squeeze them
they would start to bend so the fact
that he could throw it so hard it would
wedge
into the wall she's like yeah that man
is he's still juiced up he's still got
something like super soldier
oh yeah but what's great about this
series it seems to be exploring
that bitter reality of the character and
um
they seem to be making him a korean war
veteran which is different from the
comics
and um he was imprisoned for 30 years
which is
the biggest and saddest part about his
whole
thing because like he served his country
he even took half
of a bucky's arm off apparently in a
fight with
me and they they did him dirty and
apparently he says that even hydra
hydra um the the terrible organization
that likes to have their fingers and
many pies
um even they experimented with him and
uh that's that's gonna be pretty
interesting to learn more about as the
series goes on
yeah and it makes you wonder well hydro
is pretty much everywhere as shield if
you consider
fielding hydra is a functionally the
same organization
um the so it could have been uh shield
agents who are like actually
hail hydra and then they like you know
take some of his blood serum out or
uh if like after he was released from
because it 30 years so we don't know
when he was retired
and he was recently released from prison
or like he's been out of prison for the
past 10 years
uh and then he was like so 30 years
before that like sometime in the 80s he
was getting away
uh we're not really sure but he uh yeah
hydra
found him and that's why they're now
going to go talk to zola
uh
did i just have a uh a freudian slip
there a freudian zola
i mean yeah i mean sometimes it's zola
zola could potentially be involved
because zola was around
during the times of you know the korean
war and all that stuff in ai form
and well i forget what year that zola
actually died like the manzola
but like zola as in essence has been
around since
zola i think it was implied that zola
died sometime in the seventies
uh 1970 is when he was starting to work
on his algorithm he wasn't dead yet
because howard stark was looking for him
yeah but like based off of his age
during the 40s i think he died so
during the 70s and then the technology
of that supercomputer at camp lehigh
it was kind of like late 70s early 80s
like that was that was pretty analog
that technology they definitely
didn't have ipads they they weren't
running on uh yeah
new mac computers definitely not but
tell us about
this his grandson which it almost seemed
understated but if you look in the
credits his name is
uh eli bradley yeah elijah bradley's
played by elijah richardson
why is this guy so important so that's a
great question because
elijah bradley is one of marvel's
young avengers and that's what they seem
to be setting up with this series and
this episode
and i was really excited to see him and
um and of course elijah bradley is being
played by elijah richardson which is
great
like i hope that like the having the
name elijah was like the
the actual um like bar that they had for
this role that'd be hilarious
great you're so you're perfect for this
role but your name is brian
right oh we're really hoping for elijah
sorry
this is uh we're taking this seriously
we're sticking it closer to comics so
would you be willing to change to elijah
well my last name is elijah
you couldn't be elijah elijah it's like
no all right bye-bye
right next but the three
main takeaways um with in regards to
isaiah in this episode
um is that with isaiah the series is
exploring the racist history of the
super soldier program
in america and it seems to be pretty
messed up so
looking forward to seeing how uh
terrible these people have been to
isaiah
and which explains why the government
preferred john walker to sam wilson
because
unfortunately you know they don't have
sam wilson didn't have the right
skin for them which is some some bs but
right whatever and then you even see
that uh we don't really know where john
walker's uh morality is at right now i
could see it going either way that
opening scene in the locker room
painted him pretty sympathetically but
when he says things like i need cap's
wingman at my side and sam's just like
it's always that last slide yeah it's
like cap would never describe sam as his
wingman
like they're always on each other's left
they're partners you know so i don't
uh yeah i think the fact that he looks
down on him the way that like
battle star is his like sidekick yeah
you know that's a really
big thing and like one thing that i've
in regards to battle star
like um bucky reacted really
interestingly to the to the
name battle star so i wonder if uh bucky
has a history with the term battle star
when he was serving
in the movie oh that's how you read it i
just read it as like he's like no
this name's [ __ ] no more i'm not
hanging out with other stupid name
superheroes no
i think the government i mean i think
the government may actually be trying to
make their own
cap and bucky but um with you know
walker and
hoskins um but having hoskins be
like his wingman his number two it's
kind of just like all right we're just
going to keep the black man as the
number two and make sure we elevate the
white man and like you know right
and falcon was probably just like uh not
about that i'm not anybody's wingman we
were me and steve were partners
um but yes the racist history of the
super soldier program
is is definitely going to be something
that's going to be talked about
but second takeaway is that isaiah is
part of the history of
the human enhancement act in which super
soldier serum was given to others
and thaddeus ross thought that he is
thunderbolt ross um
a character that we've seen in previous
mcu movies um
is part on this of this program so yeah
and this is something that we found in
the end credits there's like one of the
first texts that you see before it wipes
away to someone who worked on the show
is like according to thaddeus ross uh
all information regarding the human
enhancement act is to be labeled
confidential
and directed to major donovan of special
unit blacklight blank
so the fact that ross is behind this we
know ross is involved with the super
soldier program trying to reboot it
back in the days of the incredible hulk
movie when he's working with blonsky and
he's bringing back out the cryo tanks
that contained
some of erskine's early formulas uh
reinstein was on
the label and there was a alias of
erskine and then even stark industries
for howard stark when he was working
with them
so uh yeah ross could be someone
important he could be the power broker
himself or he could be working with the
power broker but we'll talk about that
more
in a bit yes um and takeaway number
three um actually i really like that you
said all that but take away number three
is that isaiah's grandson eli as we were
talking
about before as super patriot is a
really big part of this series
or just patriot i think sometimes not
super patriot i'm sorry you're right
as patriot um excuse me is likely going
to be part of a future young
young avengers line up which will
include other older versions of billy
and tommy from wand division who
we all love and we miss them and i hope
you guys are okay
oh my god so sad yeah i'll miss you guys
um and kate bishop from the new hawkeye
series coming up which i'm personally
very excited about if you follow me on
twitter i'm a big uh haley steinfeld
uh stan uh so that's gonna be dope
and cassie lane from ant-man and the
wasp quantomania
who is being played by a different
actress than she was in endgame right
yeah it's not emma furman they have a
new
uh blonde actress blonde's always had
more fun
and possibly even kamala khan it from
the
new miss marvel show coming up and
america chavez um which is one of my
favorite
who is one of my favorite characters in
marvel and possibly i believe
torres um as falcon in the future but
we'll see because i don't believe
torres falcon has been a young avenger i
think he was more closely aligned with
the champions right
if i'm not mistaken but yeah yes um
yeah and then uh there's some other
possibilities out there that we might
see a version of iron lad
people keep saying the kid from iron man
3 hardly keener ty simpkins is coming i
i don't think i don't think so
have a different actor play the role
yeah um like but why not he's already
established it's like
they've already recast cassie lang a few
times right yeah this is the third
cassie lane we're seeing
so why wouldn't they do that right um
but uh yeah so we have a young avengers
lineup to look forward to
uh now the thing is i don't think it's
gonna be exactly the young avengers from
the comics i just think really
gonna be like a younger group of
avengers yeah and it's gonna be like a
legends of tomorrow type thing where
it's meant for younger audiences
uh and it's just kind of a team up and
and it's not going to have the same kind
of weight
uh but it will be fun in other ways oh
yeah for sure
it's like it's that that's that coming
together thing that we got in avengers 1
that is just so
great and we're seeing these characters
being introduced in their own series
and all that stuff and then when they
come together in their young avengers
project
it's gonna be like oh cool like oh it's
cassie and them and like they're
interacting and like
it's gonna be dope i'm looking forward
to it so
uh we want to talk more about the power
broker all your other questions that you
had from this episode first we want to
thank some people who helped us make
this episode starting with our friends
ed helix
so sam bucky and steve are all bad role
models for
sleeping they all sleep on the ground
and sam and steve have complained
in the past about regular mattresses
being too soft like marshmallows that
they'd sink to the floor
too soft come on that's not a pro many
of us have
and our friends at helix sleep are here
to ensure that that's never a problem
again
helix sleep has a sleep quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you they
have soft medium and firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling down if
you sleep hot or even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers i took
the quiz and helix sent me a mattress
that has changed the way i sleep it's
perfectly designed for me and i sleep
like a rock sometimes i need like
an 11 word activation code to get me out
of bed in the morning kelly's over there
like a
freight train she's like what does this
mean i'm like you're not done yet
i need you to say it all right come on
say all of it i can't wake up
and she's looking down at the ring she's
like do i really
have i made a big mistake i know i got
so lucky with this one the fact that she
puts up with me let me tell you let me
tell you
so it's not just me that loves helix
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
and uh by gq and wired magazine so helix
is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
inside marvel that's helix sleep dot com
slash inside marvel
for up to 200 off and two free pillows
we also want to thank our friends on
stereo for sponsoring new rockstars is
excited to partner with stereo
the app on uh weekly live shows just
download the stereo app for free right
now at stereo dot com slash new
rockstars if you're listening to us live
on stereo right now
uh or if you're not listening to us live
you're missing out every week we're
pumping out at least
a handful of shows previewing what's
coming up in pop culture and on the
channel and reviewing the big hits from
previous week
uh that content is completely free to
access and super easy to listen to on
your mobile device
the best part of stereo is that you get
to be part of the show submit audio
messages with your questions theories
and reactions
actually immediately after inside marvel
here we're gonna record a special q a
segment with your audio questions
that we answer live and you can go back
and listen to all of our previous
episodes of any of our shows on the
stereo app so apps
access these live shows share your
questions and theories and interact with
us in real time
by downloading the free stereo app at
stereo dot com slash new rockstars
that's stereo dot com slash new
rockstars and then finally we want to
thank our friends at blue chew
so our friends at bluetooth have a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost blue chew
is an online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within
days they're licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient in strength
and if you hate swallowing pills good
news blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name so uh you
know your fiance doesn't have to put it
in a piece of bread and sneak it into
your food
as she does for me i'm telling you i'm
gonna be the best wife in the world
my fiance is the best uh she has to put
up with all kinds of problems
and and she doesn't stride uh so if you
could benefit from extra confidence when
it's time to perform visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code
inside marvel at checkout just pay the
five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
will receive your first month free and
we thank lucha for sponsoring this show
all right mt what is our next what the
falcon
who the falcon is the power broker now
this is a really big question and as the
power broker is not messing around this
episode at all
and he's got people to kill if they mess
with them
and carly seems to be in his sight so
we're just wondering
what exactly is carly's relationship
with the power broker
and why didn't she tell her team about
that very threatening text
yeah it's interesting right i i mean i
think the power broker
i don't think it's going to be
necessarily carl malus just because carl
malus was in jessica jones i don't know
if feige is going to want to reuse that
name or create any confusion
we might just have a power broker has a
different name and it's possible that
the power broker is the same person as
thaddeus ross that he uses an alias
or he has some other kind of person
connected with him but i think ross is
going to be part of this
uh because we know he's part of the
human enhancement program we know he
oversees that operation
we have theories that he might be trying
to set up his own thunderbolts crew that
we've talked about many times on this
channel
um and i think that's uh maybe but i
don't think he would
send a text saying i'm gonna kill you
that's my one thing
yeah so i think the fact that he's like
probably high powered in the government
somewhere
he probably has someone else he's
working with and maybe
carly morgan though she has a father and
her father is a power broker and there's
just been some bad blood or some love
lost between
them uh and he's just like i'm gonna
kill you but that's how he has
it's weird that he has her number but
she doesn't have his number saved in the
phone
yeah so he somehow found her number uh
maybe through the magic of the internet
you know who's connected to the internet
is
zola swiss
bank empty that's why he's so amazing
exactly he's like you know
rob from my country all right i'm coming
after you it's zone it's gotta be zola
zola
the power broker is watching so hey zola
could be all up in the technology
watching everyone because here's the
question how the hell
did he know that it was them who robbed
his shipment
like right he's watching he's ever
i don't know how that man knew that and
how he got his no how he got carly's
number
but he's obviously connected how about
this
uh battle star said that they hacked red
wing
uh and that's why it was so glitchy last
episode is because the government
is spying on these people through sam's
tech
and so once it gets into the us
government's hand if it goes up the
thaddeus ross and he just shares it with
his computer buddy zola
then it gets back to him and then so we
see these uh the power brokers men
kill is it lennox it's one of her guys
matthias i believe
and uh and they're like it's the power
brokers man and then he calls someone on
the phone he's like they got away
so he wasn't there himself he wasn't
like in the back seat of one of those
suvs oh no i mean why wouldn't
too much oh yeah why would he he's
actually a
code a green computer ai that floats
around in an
old school computer that is somehow
still working
so like with the power broker my my
question is like i don't know which
version like
like you alluded to that we're getting
because um i know that in the comics
that power broker
works closely with malice as part of
power broker incorporated
but um the power broker has been two
people in the comics has been
curtis jackson at first and uh a
mysterious second
which is a weird like robot looking
white pale
he was not a robot he's a pale mutate
man um
that we don't really know much about so
like i'm just really interested to see
which version if we're getting
that we're getting we could even be
getting a female we could be getting
like anyone like so i'm just really
excited for the power broke i like a
good mystery
in the show and uh yeah one division got
me uh
addicted to a good marvel mystery so
yeah me too
i gotta say um all right our next what
the falcon is what the falcon is john
walker's secret
where is this guy's head at is he uh
someone who we were
uh too quick to judge or did we call a
spade a spade
that's a good question i mean so we saw
that he abruptly changed the subject
when they said
mit studied his body which is kind of a
mega sketch a little sketch but yeah
we'll see
um andy gave lamar a look when they
mentioned super soldiers so like you may
be just being like hey bro just uh
no um and three
he went over to dr rainer's head to
release bucky and skip his therapy
so yeah what does he have going on i
don't know what it is yeah i mean
my theory for now is that he and lamar
were part of the same
super human super soldier enhancement
program that the
flag smashers were i think they know
full well who the flag smashers are now
they might be different generations of
them they might have been like an
earlier class
or later class uh but i think there's
some kind of international program maybe
through the grc right the global
resources
council yeah that seems to be some kind
of u.n
government body that maybe that's what
ross is overseeing now
um but through these resources they're
trying to create like this new
initiative of super soldiers one of them
uh were there during the blip like it
probably got paused during the blip
there's some debate over whether or not
ross got blipped
according to the marvel cinematic
universe wikia it says he did
but then they're uh you can't ever just
dress a wikia because you got to look at
the sources at the bottom yeah their
source is just
the avengers end game script and i have
read the full avengers in the game
script and i re-looked at the script the
only time ross is mentioned
is he's at tony stark's funeral so i
think one person put in that entry
based on the fact that william hurt
didn't appear to age that much but
once you reach once you get past 60 you
can't tell if someone's five years older
or not
yeah sorry that's just how movies work
um so i think he could have lived or he
could have been around this whole time i
don't know but either way this would
kind of explain if he wasn't around
during the blip um
maybe these flag smashers are like we
were about to be used as these super
soldiers we were so glad everything got
blipped because now
no one can try to weaponize us so they
kind of started to build their own
black smashers one world one people cult
whatever you want to call it
yeah the flag uh flash mobbers and then
uh
yeah and then uh and then now ross is
back and he's trying to get a handle on
all them
um and he's uh he created some new ones
with uh john walker and lamar hoskins
yeah and uh so that's kind of what john
walker is trying to do he's trying to
kill off the past uh
american winter soldiers you know but
here's here's an idea that like i sort
of thought about during the course of
this episode
what if the power broker is you know
supplying everyone with powers
like it's just like a business move it's
like all right u.s government you want a
new captain america
have a little bit of this oh flax
measures you want some powers to
to do this have a little bit of that
it's like it's like that thing that they
introduced
in uh the last jedi with uh dj's
character it's like
you know it's just it's just business
this guy's just like he's making his
money
and like he doesn't really care who he
says he who he sells these powers to
so i thought you were gonna say the boys
that kind of sounds like compound v in
the boys yeah
they they kind of make it a commodity
and they sell it to the government
to give to like cops and stuff like if
everything exactly just be like a
superhuman what
yikes oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm moving to
canada oh god now they
took over canada oh god ah then i'm just
polka dot man i'm just like just kill me
i don't want to live uh but yeah i think
uh
like right now they're doing a really
good job writing john walker one way and
white russell's doing such a good job
so likable you know little moments
flashes of shitness but he's so sweet
overall
like it's so hard like being conflicted
about it because at first everyone was
just like you know what
i hate this man but like now with
russell's performance as
john walker i'm just like all right
i know you're doing your best john but
could you not
be captain america could you just give
it to sam because that's what
steve wanted but like oh man like i
definitely do feel for this man because
he does have
massive shoes to fill and well you know
where ryan
russell gets it is his dad kurt russell
like he does the same kind of tricks
that ego
does yeah volume 2 where it's like i
kind of like this guy
i kind of like him oh wait he's you know
it's
there's that balance in there that uh i
mean white russell is an actor in his
own right i'm saying he got it all from
his daddy
but like they the reason the charm the
little twinkle in the yeah
charm that gets yeah it's like yeah i
trust you now but
you're being sketchy right uh so there's
just too much about
what uh john walker's doing too much
shade it's he pulls the gun out and he
shoots one of the uh
one of them and i you know cap shoots b
cap shot people in the war
uh black widow shoots people all the
time they use deadly force sam brought
in red wing to just like
spray them with bullets on that uh so i
mean i get it it just feels really weird
right now after seeing so many years of
steve rogers cap only use his shield as
his offensive weapon
to see a cat pull out a gun it's just it
feels off-putting yeah i mean like
cap usually only uses a gun if he has to
and like he
he mainly views himself as a defender
of just freedom in general and so like
for
for walker to have a gun at the ready at
all times which is something that steve
has never done
is just like a statement like i am a
weapon i am a weapon i'm not a defender
i am
weapon man and i'm here to serve weapon
man
gun arms knife fingers
grenade feet it's so hard to walk
that's just a mega man that's just like
a really bad mega man right so you have
to be it's just
gonna get sued by capcom yeah yeah all
right so
another what the falcon uh will bucky
and sam do to get zemo out of prison
how's that conversation gonna go what
what are they gonna talk about how's
this gonna go i mean
hey i mean i i assume that bucky's gonna
be like hey zuma you have any good
stories you can read me you want to read
me a good story
i'm just kidding though um no because
bucky's gonna be real pissed as we see
in the trailers you know bucky does have
this face off with zemo
and it's really uh not great he seems
pretty pissed as he should be
so well it seemed to be like bucky's
suggestion to go to zemo oh yeah it's
weirded me out it's like so
if you're willing to go talk to him
right now like
just the writing of this seems to be a
little like i'd like a bit of an answer
of where
these characters heads are at yeah like
the bucky i knew would never want to see
zemo again
i don't understand why bucky's so eager
would just go wolverine and say [ __ ] off
i don't want to join this mission
like to talk to zemo again this guy who
like tortured me
and used me like i don't think he would
ever wanna it would be
sam who would be like hey ain't zemo
somewhere in a prison in europe
well if you remember at the end of um
bucky and sam's little therapy session
he goes oh what was rule number two
again
don't hurt anybody okay so maybe in his
mind he was already gonna go to zeno
because zemo was on his list
so he's like you know what let's do two
birds of one stone we probably
gotta learn more about hydra anyway so
let's run it out of um
zemo and then i'm gonna hurt this man
because he hurt me
so yeah that's just i i guess i can see
that now i think the zemo
conversation i don't think they're gonna
let him go talk to zemo i think they're
gonna have to arrange to break him out
right like maybe that's the deal he's
like i'll help you get to the next step
if you get me out of here
because you're gonna need me to get into
madrapore to find this power broker or
something like that
they're gonna be like oh fine we'll
break you out
but cause i think that that same prison
facility we
saw footage in the trailer of like uh
security forces running through and
prisoners being
lined up outside their cells as they do
a head count so i think there's going to
be some kind of prison break
i mean i mean falcon has the white
panther on his team so that should be
real easy
i love that white wolf call back that
was i know i was like
as soon as you said white panther like
they better say white wolf they better
say it they better say it yeah
than they did but like
yeah so like i i am interested to see
how they get zemo out of prison because
yeah um it's gonna be it has to be
really elaborate i wonder if they're
gonna work with zemo because
i wonder if zemo breaks himself out
because he'd be the type of person to do
that
by the time they get there he's like
like in the suicide squad trailer oh you
guys came to break me out oh my god
you're so nice
we got a whole plan um all right so uh
let's close out with another segment of
oh cat my cap we're gonna
go through the potential cap successors
in this episode i'm just gonna rate them
either that's my cap
or not my cap let's start with sam
wilson here
not my cap or that's my cat he's always
in my cap bro you know it bro
you know how about you uh this episode
uh i'm gonna say not my cap i think he
is not interested in the captain america
legacy okay uh
and uh i i'm not really sure where sam
is at right now because he's
uh he doesn't want to work with the rest
of the team it's kind of antagonizing
bucky
uh he's uh and he's super pissed off at
the whole legacy of captain america
i i don't know this week less less cap
for me for sam wilson
okay i mean that's fair okay that's fair
uh what about bucky barnes
bucky barnes for this week hmm i think
that bucky barnes is my cat because he
cares a lot about
the legacy of of captain america and he
keeps
bothering sam he's like why'd you give
it up he gave it to you
he didn't give it to me he gave it to
you why'd you give it up like this is
he cared about the shield and if he was
wrong about you then he was wrong about
me and that broke me
that was just like oh he just he wants
to be better and
he wants to be better because steve
believed in him and
in part because steve believed him so
like yeah i think bucky's
gonna get my cap respect this episode
yeah me too
bucky uh definitely jumped up and he
seemed to understand the legacy of the
shield
uh and be super defensive over that so
bucky is yeah that's my cap
what about john walker john walker see
this is tough
because i obviously have my loyalties to
steve but like this episode
russell really brought it and i
a part of me just like i really want to
give this guy a shot because he
genuinely wants to do the right thing
so i'm a little iffy i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say he's my cat for just for
this week i'm gonna say
walker's my cat because i liked
russell's performance yes me too and
this might be the only week we say that
empty i
firmly believe that next week in the
week after we'll be like why did we ever
say that
yeah it's like what do we get on video
that opening locker room scene was
enough to be like okay yeah this guy
seems to be just as uncomfortable with
the whole uh song and dance routine
of a star spangled man with the plan
that steve rogers was uncomfortable so
yeah um and let's just skip down to
isaiah bradley
yes isaiah bradley he's i know i've said
my cap to everyone so far but like he's
gotta be
he's gotta be my cap he went through too
much garbage
to not get the respect so i gotta give
it up isaiah bradley that's my cap
yeah he is the the cap in the saddest
and most frustrating part of that
history of
like someone who is just a government
instrument
yeah and is just there for his flesh and
his blood
and the way he can be used to bring more
depth and pain and destruction in the
world
and he's so bitter over that and i'm so
glad they're exploring that
uh on this show um because it is a
really messed up thing
yeah um and if you were to actually ask
the real world implications of if we had
a government super soldier
how would our government use them uh
it's not going to be a very happy story
yeah i'm just looking forward to hear
more about
his that past and uh like all the messed
up things that they did to him and like
if there's more and like if there's like
how many people
died um trying to get isaiah bradley
superpowers because in the comics they
just grabbed a bunch of just
african-american people
and were like all right and try to
enhance them and isaiah bradley was one
of the few people that survived so it's
just like
seeing that history of um of forgotten
black people that have tried to
you know serve their country um will be
interesting uh moving forward
yeah uh and i'm i'm just so glad they're
addressing it on this show
like um it's they seem to be doing it
the right way
and carl lumley the performance he's
bringing
is just heartbreaking and as you said
yeah the guy
already that scene alone that's emmy
nomination worthy
100 goddamn it was so great um
okay well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel the after show for the
falcon winter soldier
uh mt and i will be back next friday for
reaction episode three
and our after show in which we're gonna
answer all the big questions he had
about the episode
uh reminder to download the stereo app
by going to stereo.com rockstar so you
can listen to our weekly live shows
submit questions and theories and hear
us respond in real time download the app
for free on apple and android and create
an avatar profile mt
and i are now gonna turn to our
listeners on stereo
for all of their wonderful questions in
a bonus q a
segment that's i think it's going to go
up on the channel on sunday
so that'll be a treat uh follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at ea boss
follow new rockstar subscribe to inside
marvel
wherever you get your podcast thank you
for watching and we'll close out with
our favorite one of the episode little
time in wakanda and you come out white
panther
it's actually white wolf huh
[Music]
you
[Music]